Let's think about what the two different
versions of Caroline's repository look
like at this point.
Here's what the local version looked
like before Caroline interacted with
GitHub at all.
Then, she pushed the master branch.
And then, since the commits were on
the master branch, everything got sent.
So at that point,
they had exactly the same history.
Then Caroline edited a file
directly on GitHub and
made a commit on the master branch,
updating master.
So, this is where we are now.
Her local version is out of date
with the remote GitHub version.
To get the repositories back into sync,
she'll need to pull her master
back into the local version.
This will bring the new commit into
the local version and update master.
Now I'll hand you off to Caroline
to see this on the command line.
>> Thanks, Sarah.
Now, like you saw,
the commit that I just made is shown in
the commit history on the GitHub site.
However, when I run git log,
I can see that that commit isn't
present in my local repository.
To get it, I'll run git pull.
Like when I run git push,
I need to specify the remote,
which I've named origin.
For pull, I'll also need to
specify the branch I want to pull,
which is the master
branch on the remote.
Before I ran git pull,
I had some commits in my local
repository which I'd pushed to git hub.
I also had a new commit on GitHub,
adding the lesson three
reflections file.
When I pulled the master branch from
the origin repository, that is,
my repository on GitHub, it pulled
all of the commits reachable from
the master branch on GitHub
down into my local repository.
In this case,
I had the master branch checked out, so
git also updated my local master branch
label to point to the new command.
Now, it's not necessary for
these two names to be the same,
but they usually are.
Then, I'll run git log again, and
I can see that my new commit is
present in my local repository now.
Now go ahead and
pull the changes you just made in
GitHub into your local repository.
When you're finished,
which of the following is true?
Are there changes in
your local repository that
are not present on GitHub?
Are there changes on GitHub that
are not in your local repository?
Or is neither true?
All the changes in your local repository
are present on GitHub and vice versa.